[Music]
would you eat meat grown in a lab
last december a world first was created
when a singaporean restaurant
sold a box of chicken nuggets that were
completely lab grown
so-called cultured meat is the future
and means that we won't have to kill
animals for food in the years to come
at least that's what the mp anthony
brown argues in his article for the
spectator this week
i'm joined now by dr mark cotter from
cambridge and also co-founder
of meetable a company which is on track
to produce cultured pork
in just a couple of years dr cotter
welcome to spectator tv can you start by
explaining to the layman what
cultured meat means hi cindy thank you
very much for having me on the show
so cultured meat is really the concept
of
creating real meat
in in a lab um removing the requirement
of large scale and animal farming
can you explain what the life process of
that looks like how do you grow like
meeting a lab so i think we've seen sort
of
meat substitutes become popular in the
past couple of years and these are often
based on plant-based sources
um cultured meat really wants to create
the real thing
the real thing which is consists mainly
of muscle
tissue and fat tissue
um and remove the sort of requirement of
animal farming do this actually in in a
lab
and the way that this works is that you
use
bioreactors which are you know culture
conditions
uh um that um have the cells floating
in 3d and and allowing them
to grow up and then you want to
put them into molds essentially
that allow them to grow muscle bundles
and fat tissue i think that would be the
ideal way of doing this
sounds very simple it's actually very
very difficult um
and and there's been sort of slow
um pro progress until more recently when
when things really sped up
well that brings me to my next question
actually which is how far away
is this technology i think we made some
leaps uh um recently and
i i can i can tell you about uh the
company that i'm involved in
which is called mutable essentially it
came out
of an invention it was created based on
an invention that
my academic laboratory did together with
professor ludovic's laboratory at the
stem cell institutes in cambridge
um and what this allowed us to do is to
really make this process of creating
these fat cells and these and these
and these muscle cells very very
efficiently that's been really
the bottleneck so being able to create
um specific cell types is not only a
problem
uh for cultured meat it's also a problem
in other fields like medicine
you know i'm my bet my background is a
medical doctor
so so that's that was my primary
interest
but we happen to discover a process
that is very very efficient and scalable
and so the idea of meetable is to
to develop this process to create these
uh products
um meat products at scale and how far
are we away
i believe we're going to see first
prototypes um on display
um this year and i think there'll be
there'll be a small production
um in the next two years or so
so i think we're very close this field
has made a huge leap
so by the end of the year we could see
it in supermarkets
on the shelves next to the vegetarian
options this real meat but that hasn't
been
an animal hasn't been killed in the
process no i i i refer to a prototype
so it's a small selective production
that you know
showcases this and allows the regulators
to approve it
very interesting and are there parts of
um meats that you can't replicate so
much
i'm thinking for example um things like
ribs like the bone part of things
is the meat that you create are they
going to be just lumps of meat
essentially so
all those other parts of an animal
presumably you can't replicate that
look what bioengineering um has
provided us uh within the last um
10 years is really tools to to really
think
think big and i do think that it's
possible to actually
create something that looks like a bone
3d printing of calcium etc um
but um let's be pragmatic the first
product
that you want to bring into
the market is obviously something that's
very simple to produce
and the simplest products i would say
are minced meat
sausages and things like that but i
think
that already has the potential that a
real step
change in terms of how we think about
meat
how we think about the origin of meat um
and also it allows us to open up a
future
where you know we are less less reliant
on on on on the resources that really
put a big strain on on our on our planet
yes and let's come to some of those pros
in in just a second because people might
be wondering you know
why bother but first of all do you think
that this
tastes like meat um i mean i know that
biologically it is but are there parts
of an animal's growing experience all
around the world you hear about you know
grass-fed beef or whatever it is
part of the animal's diet or exercise
that makes the meat taste different
can you do anything about that when
you've only got the dna
well i do think if you that you actually
have even greater flexibility
um if you have something in an
industrial process
so it's much less left to
whatever happens to the outside
i think what i'm trying to say here is
once you apply
an engineering approach to biology and i
think this happens now broadly
uh across various spectra um
then then your your tool set your
abilities actually increase and you can
do
things that you may have not thought
about um
i can think of some really strange
things like
um creating creating
meat from different species and having
it in one
um so so fine tuning a bit like you know
a good wine
or or you could also you know oh
well like a like a meat with a dna of a
pig and a
and a cow and then seeing what that
would taste like that's right having
having those cells together in in in one
in one um you know piece of meat
essentially
hmm interesting i think we'll have to
get get viewers to email in on their
thoughts about that and what
combinations of me
sure i think we're talking about the
future at this point
yeah i think uh um this technology has
has um a chance to address some of the
sort of
real pain points including
including the reason why you know we're
sat
yes stuck in zoom boxes at the moment
and
not being able to travel freely i think
uh
you know intensive farming um
comes with the risk of uh viruses um
transmitting
from from from animals to human
yes absolutely and can you talk a little
bit about the benefits
that you see with with this approach is
one day we won't be have to kill animals
for farming
ever is that right yes absolutely i
think that's uh
one of the drivers animal welfare
considerations i think um on top of my
personal
uh agenda as well um although i do like
meat
i do eat meat so i don't want to sort of
pretend that i'm um
a vegetarian at this point in time um
the second aspect of course is um you
know the conditions under which animals
are you know raised uh
uh and and slaughtered i think here um
having an alternative is
is really really important
uh another aspect is um the
environmental impact
and also the medical impact of the
current way of producing meat
so we all heard about the use of
antibiotics
in farms and what that means is that
a lot of antibiotics are used across
across the globe which don't
help patients so to speak but make
bugs become more resistant
and we feel the effects of that
in in the clinic we have an increase in
ins in bugs and strains that cannot be
treated
with the regular set of antibiotics
so i think it's key one key aspect of
cultured meat is to be able to
sort of reduce the broad application of
antibiotics
as a doctor that's of course something
that's that's really important
and and then there's this other aspect
that
that i think people are becoming more
more aware of
which is really the greenhouse gas um
that
that is emissions that are associated
especially with
uh cattle and
in fact i think it's one of the largest
single
contributors contributors to to
greenhouse gases
um and so having an alternative
in this space i think is also something
um that that is very valuable
and finally we all know that meat's not
always healthy
and and that's sometimes because of
you know certain fats that are in in
in meats and if you let's go back to
this engineering approach
what you could what you could
essentially do is you know you could
take out some of those um non-healthy
um you know substances that uh that we
see
although i think again we're talking
more about the future
yes of course um and is all of this
safe you know when we come talking about
um gm
foods for example a lot of people's
concerns are that it's not safe and what
you're doing is not just mod it's not
modifying genetics obviously but you're
recreating it and you're growing
meat and which could be the main basis
of our diet
is that a safe thing to do to be
consuming i mean let's be honest
uh when we culture meat it's an
artificial process
it's it's a synthetic process um the
question then becomes
um is the is the product safe or not
and that's essentially so so you know i
think uh
um we just need to recognize that this
is not something that happens without
you know an industrial machine behind it
now the the the the good thing is that
um
we have a lot of experience
um you know our society was regulating
um aspects of food
and aspects of health you know there's a
system that checks every drug that is
developed there's a system that
uh looks at every new food uh that
that's being put out and and i and i do
trust that
um that the robustness of
of these systems um and so i do think uh
if you ever want to create a product
that can be used
it has to it has to jump all the hoops
and
and all the checks um that that are
required to make it a safe product
so i wouldn't feel comfortable at all um
if
we sort of decide if there would be
someone who to decide to go forward with
a product that isn't safe
yes absolutely well it's interesting
that you mentioned the regulators
because
in anthony brown's piece for the
spectator this week he talks about how
the singaporean regulators
have given the green light for something
like this but
in the eu for example there's a bit more
reluctance
and he mentions that in brussels and
washington lobbyists from
the farming industry have made have are
making efforts so that
the word meat can only be applied to
meat that comes from
animals being slaughtered i mean you
must be coming up against quite a lot of
opposition inertia
yeah i i do think if you come with
something
that's a very disruptive idea and
by no way in way i want to claim that
this was my idea i think there's a whole
field out there but if you're part of
something that's
novel uh you you are going to ruffle
feathers
and and and cause some pushback and i
think some of that pushback is
um is good because it um
basically means that you have to up your
game you have to show
uh that uh what what you generate what
you produce is actually better
in in in so many aspects um
i think there's also a little bit of
sort of fear
uh in certain pockets um
[Music]
what's interesting though is that um if
you look at
the sentiment of of of the users you
know the man on the street and the women
on the street
that we can see a real swing away from
you know
um from this is
artificial we don't want to touch it to
some
to to a sort of new mindset uh where
people are aware
of all the problems that our current
system has
and where people decide to become vegan
or vegetarian
not because they don't like meat but
because they don't like the process
uh and and and the animals the wealth uh
aspects
of it and and this particular sort of
um you know group of people which is
which is large um i believe um
is very in favor for for for a meat
alternative
even though uh it is it is you know
something that comes out of the lab
yes well as a fair vegetarian i can very
much get behind that
and i'm intrigued by this idea of the
hybrid sausage
dr mark cotter thank you very much for
joining spectator tv
thank you so much
[Music]
you